Bitte schön.
Ja, ich fange an.
Ja, los gehts.
Grüß Gott, ich bin Dr. Matt. Ich bin zuständiger Arzt für Sie.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerde sprechen.
So als bräuchte ich ein paar Persönlichandaten, dann sprechen wir genau über Ihre Beschwerde.
Wie lutet Ihr Name?
Ich heiße Martha Baumgart.
Martha Baumgart. Können Sie Ihren Nachname buchstabieren?
Ja, wie der Baum, B-A-U-M oder G-A-R-T.
Und Vorname bitte?
Martha, M-A-R-T-H-A.
T-H-A-A. Frau Martha Baumgart.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
66 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 8. Februar 57.
8. Februar 57, ja.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie Frau Baumgart?
Ja, Sie stellen schwierige Fragen. Ich bin 1 Meter 56.
56.
Und ich wiege 84 Kilo.
Ich weiß, dass das zu viel ist.
Ich will Ihnen abzunehmen.
Wenn das man so leicht wäre.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Was kann ich für Sie tun, Frau Baumgart?
Ja, wissen Sie, heute Morgen ging das mit einmal los.
Ich hatte ganz, jetzt ist es zum Glück ein bisschen besser,
aber ich hatte heute Morgen ganz heftige Schmerzen,
ich habe es so gezogen, so, und zwar hier oben in der Brust, ja.
Es war ganz beängstigend.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich kann kaum Luft bekommen.
Ich habe richtig Angst bekommen.
Und nachher in Ruhe ist es wieder besser geworden.
Aber ich habe das auch gemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen strahlten so in den linken Arm rein.
Und das ging auch so hoch in den Hals.
Es war ganz beängstigend.
Und es waren wirklich kraftige Schmerzen.
Bekommen wir sich über Luft?
Ja, normalerweise, also jetzt nicht mehr,
aber heute Morgen hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass ich so für den Moment nicht Luft kriegen konnte, ja.
Und eben diese sehr heftigen Schmerzen,
das Strahle bis hier, ist hier so in den Kinnbereich rein.
Das war wirklich sehr unheimlich.
Alles klar.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerz, die ist von 0 bis 10,
wobei 0 klein sind, sind sehr starke Schmerzen nicht.
Ja, wie soll ich das sagen?
Wahrscheinlich waren die schon so bei 7, 8.
Das waren wirklich heftige Schmerzen.
Zum Glück ist es jetzt wieder ein bisschen besser.
Aber diese Angst ist irgendwie jetzt noch da, ne?
Können Sie diese Schmerzen gerne beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen dumpf, brennend oder stehend?
Vielleicht, also sie sind so ziehend
und vielleicht drückend eher,
dass ich so ganz heftigen Druck auf der Brust hatte, ja.
Okay, brav, Herr Profer, ich muss das an einem Netzgespräch unterbrechen.
Das sind, dass ich um eine Notfall der Patient
sofort möglich stationell aufnehmen.
Und wir müssen aufgenommen werden.
Wir sollen eine E-Kalke schreiben.
Und wir sollen die Patiente monitorisieren.
Aber das ist eine Berührung, da ich weiter war.
Jetzt machen wir weiter, genau.
Sehr gut, aber gut reagiert, ja.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausröser?
Ja, also ich habe das jetzt schon manchmal so ein bisschen gehabt,
wenn ich mich angestrengt habe,
dass ich mal so eine Treppe hoch gelaufen bin,
dass ich so gedacht habe, das wird aber jetzt anstrengend.
Und heute Morgen ist es gekommen, da habe ich halt in meiner Küche
eine schwere Wasserkiste weggeräumt und wollte die eine andere Stelle tun
und so eine Kiste mit Rudelflaschen.
Und dann fing es mir einmal an.
Und das habe ich dann alle stehen und liegen lassen
und dann habe ich mich einfach erstmal in Sessel gesetzt
und gewartet, dass es mir wieder besser geht.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ich musste mit einem einmal so komisch husten.
Es war so ganz trockener Hüsten.
Trockener Hüsten, ja.
Seit wann leiteten Sie unter trockener Hüsten?
Das habe ich eigentlich schon ziemlich lange, also bestimmt schon.
Ja, schon den ganzen Sommer durch, also eigentlich vier Monate schon.
Aber das habe ich immer gedacht, ja, das geht auch wieder weg.
War denn Sie deswegen schon bei Mars?
Nein, wegen so ein bisschen Husten geht man ja nicht zum Arzt.
Aber ich bin natürlich regelmäßig beim Arzt,
weil ich immer Medikamente brauche.
In meinem Alter hat man ja viele Sachen.
Aber da haben wir jetzt nicht speziell darüber gesprochen.
Ist Ihnen Öbert oder müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Das muss ich nicht. Nein.
Ist Ihnen vielleicht geschwollener Bein aufgefahren?
Nee, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Hab ich aber auch nicht darauf geachtet, aber es mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie da irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe nur meine üblichen Medikamente genommen,
die ich so jetzt eigentlich ja schon regelmäßig nehme.
Also wegen Blutdruck und wegen Blutfett.
Dann nehme ich Bed-Med-For-Me-In,
weil ich schon lange jetzt so ein Diabetes habe.
Also ich nehme jede Menge Tabletten.
Aber jetzt speziell gegen diese Beschwerden habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Aber sehr viel war, schüttet bloß oder nach Schweiß?
Nee, geschwitzt habe ich nicht.
Ich habe mich natürlich nicht gemessen,
aber ich habe mich auch nicht fieberig. Nein.
Hab ich Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen gesagt, starke Schmerzen.
Zum Glück jetzt wieder ein bisschen besser.
Das Unangenehme war, dass diese Schmerzen in den Armen
und sie hoch ausgestrahlt haben.
Das fand ich so ein bisschen unheimlich.
Ich glaube Ihnen, Frau Baumgart,
mussten Sie mehrere Kisten, wenn Sie beim Schrafen?
Ja, also zwei Kisten habe ich schon so in meinem Bett,
aber das finde ich jetzt noch nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Wie viele Treppen können Sie beschwarten,
wenn Sie frei laufen?
Normalerweise konnte ich immer so meine zwei Treppen hochgehen,
aber in letzter Zeit ist das ein bisschen schlechter geworden.
Alles klar.
Ich meine, ich habe auch ein bisschen Gewicht mit mir rumzutragen.
Hab ich Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Neu seit heute wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
was da noch neu gekommen ist, denn das langt mir völlig.
Wie ist dir Appetit?
Normalerweise ist er ziemlich gut.
Heute habe ich jetzt nicht so richtig Hunger.
Ist dir stolz oder was ist das?
Der Stuhlgang ist, würde ich doch sagen, der ist normal.
Mussten Sie mehrmals ausgehören, ich war auf der Toilette in der Nacht?
Ja, ich muss schon fast jede Nacht zwei, drei Mal raus, aber schon länger eigentlich.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Apportose genommen?
Na schön, wenn ich abgenommen hätte, habe ich aber nicht.
Nee.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nicht wirklich gut, nein, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Haben Sie Probleme, eine oder zwei Schlafen?
Ja, eigentlich mehr so beim Einschlafen, ja, und dann weckt mich natürlich auch das auf,
dass ich auch die Toilette muss.
Alles klar.
Nun würde ich Ihre Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Frau Baumgart, Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie haben einen Blutdruck, ja, seit wann leiden Sie?
Ja, Blutdruck habe ich natürlich, aber hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Ja, seit wann leiden Sie einen Blutdruck, Blutdruck?
Also zehn Jahre ist das jetzt schon.
Und seit wann leiden Sie einen Blutvertwerb?
Ja, also das hat man halt alles zusammen festgestellt, ne?
Da bin ich mal vor zehn Jahren beim Arzt gewesen und dann hat er festgestellt,
oh, Sie haben ja hohen Blutdruck, die Blutvertwerte sind auch nicht gut.
Und dann hat er eben auch noch festgestellt, dass ich so ein Diabetes-Typ II habe.
Und na ja, da war ich natürlich gut bedient, ne?
Und seitdem nehme ich die ganzen Tabletten.
Welche, was für Reihen-Tablete nehmen Sie?
Ja, ich nehme also Aspirin und dann nehme ich Pantohexal.
Pantohexal?
Und dann nehme ich Metformin, nämlich.
Und Walzacan, nämlich auch noch, zum Blutdruck senken.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Aspirin?
Ja, das ist Aspirin 100.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay, und Metformin?
Metformin, das steht 500 drauf, dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends auch.
Und Pantohexal?
Pantohexal, das ist ja, wenn man so sauer aufstoßen muss, das heißt, wo weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, wie viel da drin ist.
Aber das nehme ich auch nicht regelmäßig, das nehme ich nur, wenn es bedarf ist.
Mhm, wenn es bedarf ist.
Aber Sie kennen die Dosierung nicht, ja?
Ich weiß das jetzt nicht, was da auf der Packung steht, nein.
Okay, und Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Walzacan?
Ich meine, da steht 160 drauf, dann nehme ich morgens eine.
160, ja?
160, ja.
160, ja, abends, oder?
Morgens.
Morgens, schuldigung.
Mhm.
Ja, außerdem Blutdruck, erhöhte Fettwerte und Diabetes Minitus leiden Sie an noch anderer Vorrang, ne?
Ja, vor drei Jahren ist mal, was doof ist passiert, da hatte ich so ein Gicht-Anfall und seitdem muss ich ein bisschen Essen noch mehr aufpassen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Welcher Seite hatten Sie, oder wo hatten Sie Gicht-Anfall?
Ja, in dem rechten C, das war sehr heftig.
Welcher C?
Okay.
Was noch?
Ja, das reicht mir völlig.
Ja, allerdings, ja, habe ich auch noch vor, wie lange ist das jetzt schon her?
Vor acht Jahren habe ich im linken Knie ein neues Gelenk bekommen, weil ich nicht mehr gut laufen konnte.
Mhm.
Das ist klar.
Denken, ja, nur.
Mhm.
Okay, haben Sie alle Vorrag-Rankungen erwähnt?
Ja, ich glaube ja, mehr als genug, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie alle mit Geräumente erwähnt?
Ich meine ja, das ist alles, was ich nehme, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Baumga, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Wie gesagt, die Knieoperation, ne?
Mhm, knieperzi… ja, genau.
Sind Sie aus anderem Grund operiert worden?
Ne, sonst bin ich nie.
Wurden Ihnen aus anderem Grund stationär aufgenommen?
Nee, war sie, ewig nicht, also vor acht Jahren war ich zuletzt in Kranen gegratet.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sieht bei Ihnen Allergie in Becken?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie gegen Jod und ich habe auch eine Allergie gegen Venezilien.
Das muss ich immer angeben, wenn ich irgendwo zum Arzt gehe.
Da habe ich auch so eine Allergie passen.
Das ist gut. Sie müssen immer Allergie passen, dabei haben.
Wie äußerst sich Jod-Allergie?
Ja, also mit so Hautausschlag und ja.
Und wie ausser sich die Venezilien angehen?
Ja, das war schon ein bisschen… also hatte ich so ein komisches, so ein komisches Geschmack im Mund und das war…
das war irgendwie schon so, dass ich auch ein bisschen Luftnot hatte, also das ist mir gar nicht gut bekommen.
Okay, eines klar vertragen Sie mich, Produkte, getreide Produkte, ob es oder genügend.
Da kann ich alles essen, ja.
Das ist gut. Trauchen Sie Frau Baumgart?
Ja, schon lange nicht mehr, seit ich diese ganzen Krankheiten habe, da habe ich aufgehört.
Aber seit wann trauchen Sie nicht?
Seit zehn Jahren. Aber vorher habe ich schon für viele Jahre, so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag, 15 Zigaretten am Tag habe ich schon geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Oh, früh angefangen und dann eben ja 35 Jahre waren das wohl.
35 Jahre haben wir es geletzt. Aber das ist sehr gute Entscheidung Frau Baumgart, das ist sehr schwierig, aber Sie haben das geschafft.
Ja, das ist gut. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz wenig mal, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt oder so, aber ganz wenig, nicht frekulmäßig.
Was, was meine ich Sie ganz wenig, ein Glas oder ein Flasche?
Eine Flasche Bier oder mal zwei Gläser Wein oder ein Glas Sekt und hinterher noch ein Wein.
Aber ja nur an besonderen Tagen, wenn es irgendwas Besonderes ist.
Alles klar.
Proteinmäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit dem Tragen haben?
Mit Roben? Nein, also in meinem Alter, ich bitte Sie, nein, nein, nein, da habe ich nie etwas mit zu tun.
Ja, das ist nur eine Proteinfrage. Wie ist Ihr Verwittwett?
Ich bin Verwittwett, mein Mann ist vor zwei Jahren beim Autounfall ums Leben gekommen.
Es tut mir leid, Frau Baumgart, das ist eine sehr schwierige Situation.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Oh ja, wir haben vier Kinder, aber wir sind ja schon völlig groß.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja ja, zum Glück.
Gott sei Dank. Was sind Sie, ja Sie sind in Rente, was haben Sie für Ihre gemacht?
Ja, ich habe als Schneiderin gearbeitet.
Das ist ein guter Beruf, ja. Sind Sie oft stresslos?
Nein, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, jetzt bin ich ja Rentnerin und so.
Ich habe nicht Stress, die Kinder gehen auch ihren Weg, also ich habe nicht Stress.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir zur Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Vorurkrankungen?
Ja, alles sind irgendwie krank gewesen, ja.
Meine Mutter ist sehr früh gestorben, die hatte Leberkrebs, die ist nur 60 Jahre alt geworden.
Und mein Vater, der ist jetzt schon über 90 Jahre alt, der lebt noch,
aber das ist auch kein Vergnügen, der hat den Demenz und ist im Pflegeheim.
Und ja, das ist auch keine gute Situation.
Ja, haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Geschwester, ja, die ist deutlich jünger als ich,
aber die hat vor einem Jahr einen Herzinfarkt.
Ja, ist das ein Vergnügen?
Es tut mir leid, ist sie verstorben?
Nein, nein, nein, die hat das gut überstanden,
die ist gleich in ärztliche Behandlung gekommen und dann hat man sie wieder aufgepeppelt.
Also die muss jetzt vorsichtig sein, aber die hat das überstanden.
Okay, Frau Barmkatz, Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie seit Morgen
eine siehende und drückende Brustschirmes haben.
Und diese Schmerzen schmerzen in die Arme und in die Unterkiefe aus.
In den linken Armen und in den unterkiefteten?
Ja, und Sie haben Angst davor und die Schmerzen normalerweise
treten die Schmerzen bei Belastung auf, aber sie haben auch momentan in Ruhe
Brustschirmes.
Minimal nur noch, ja.
Okay, Frau Barmkatz, das war meine Frage, haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was passiert jetzt, was kann man denn dagegen tun, dass das nicht wieder kommt?
Ja, Frau Barmkatz, wir haben nur noch einen Anämsgeschef geführt.
Ich brauche auch ein paar Untersuchungen.
Ich würde so Erzgeber-Pellikuntersuche dann Blut abnehmen.
Natürlich brauche ich eine EKG schreiben.
Dann kann ich Ihnen, dann kann ich Sie genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Das ist gut.
Ja, dann geht es jetzt weiter mit der Untersuchung und dann,
wo muss ich dahin gehen?
Eigentlich müssen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich würde der Köp-Pellikuntersuchung dann Blut abnehmen
und gegeneinander fast...
Dann gehe ich jetzt ins Wartezimmer, oder wie?
Ja, genau, Sie können...
Dann gehe ich jetzt ins Wartezimmer, gut.
Aber wir sollen jetzt Sie stationär aufnehmen.
Okay, gut.
Ich bin da und Schwestern auch da.
Also ja, klar, ich bin ja eigentlich schon in der Anäms-Pellikuntersuche.
Weil ich schon Monitoring habe, ja, sorry, ja.
Ja, alles klar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Perfekt.
Gerne.
Frau Baumgart, wissen Sie, wie viele Minuten Ihre Schmerzen dauern?
Oh, das ist mir ewig vorgekommen, wahrscheinlich war das gar nicht so lange.
Aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das sehr lange war,
weil das sehr heftige Schmerzen waren.
Aber ich habe nicht auf die Uhr geguckt,
ich weiß nicht, wie lange das gedauert hat.
Frau Baumgart, darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Immer.
Haben Sie kalte Schweiß oder kalte Schmerze bemerkt während der Schmerzen?
Hat der Kollege gefragt, habe ich verneint.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, die Impfstatus ist noch fehlt.
Ach ja, Impfstatus hat er nicht gefragt, stimmt ja.
Also ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft und Kinderkrankheiten,
so was alles, das ist ja schon lange her.
Aber die Corona-Impfung habe ich auf alle Fälle, ja.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden, Zottbirennen oder Soires auf Stossen?
Also jetzt akut nicht.
Manchmal habe ich das, deswegen nehme ich ja Kantohexzahl hin und wieder.
Aber jetzt im Augenblick ist das nicht schlimmer als sonst.
Ja, diese Fragen müssen wir gestattet,
weil Geld, Gastroesie, Vergel, Reflex, disease immer denken.
Ach, okay, ja, okay.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, man haben Sie meist einmal etwas gegessen, fast gegessen, ja.
Das ist wichtig.
Wichtige Frage, ja, stimmt, haben Sie recht.
Jetzt muss ich das tatsächlich überlegen.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich zum Frühstück zuletzt etwas gegessen und dann ging das los.
Haben Sie Herzstolpen oder Herzgruppen bemerkt?
Ich meine, haben Sie gefragt, habe ich aber eigentlich verneint,
das müsste jetzt das EKG zeigen.
Ja, gerne.
Schöntin, wie ist das für Sie?
Ja, gut.
Bitte benutzen Sie alle Fachbegriffe,
die Sie haben.
Okay.
Grüß Gott Frau Operatzen, wir haben eine neue Patientin,
nämlich Marta Baumgart.
Ich würde über Sie berichten. Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Frau Marta Baumgart ist 66 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 56 groß, 4,80 kg schwer.
Wie ist das für Sie heute?
Ich habe es heute Morgen, 5 Uhr,
auf dieser Seite.
Auf dieser Seite?
Ja, auf dieser Seite.
Heute Morgen?
Ja, heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen.
Sie haben die drückende, heftige Vorrachtsümerzien bei uns vor.
Laut der Patienten sind die Schmerzen belastend abhängig aufgetreten
und die Intensität der Schmerzen,
die Sie bewertet, die Intensität der Schmerzen mit 7 von 10.
Als begleitende Symptome klackte sie über belastungsabhängige
Torachschmerzen seit Langem Reisfusten,
Todesangst, Orthopne und Nocturil.
Die Vegetative einer Mese ergab in Appetence und Insomnia.
An Vorerkrankungen sind bei ihm die Folgen dann bekannt,
bei ihr die Folgen dann bekannt.
Seit 10 Jahren Atelierle, Hypertony, seit 10 Jahren Blut,
und der Betisminitiptus,
vor 3 Jahren Atritis Fureka,
vor 3 Jahren Podagra am rechten Seeherr.
An der rechten Seeherr?
Vor 8 Jahren ist bei ihr eine Knie-Tipp eingesetzt worden.
Sie, Frau Baumgart, nimmt aus Beginn 100 mg morgens und abends
mit Formen 500 mg morgens und abends.
Panthehexal,
das ist unbekannt bei Bedar,
Wasser dann 160 mg morgens und abends.
J-Allergie ist bei ihr bekannt,
diese Allergie äußerst sich mit exanter.
Außerdem ist bei ihm Penicillin Allergie bekannt,
diese Allergie äußerst sich mit Parästhesi im Mund.
Und Dyskner.
Unvertretlichkeiten sind bei ihr unbekannt.
Frau Baumgart ruft seit 10 Jahren nicht, davor hat sie 35 Jahren
und die 5 Jahre sind aufgeräumt.
Sie trinkt 2 Gläser Wein beim Anlass.
Die Drogenkonsum wurde vermittelt.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie ist verwidert und hat 4 Kinder.
Sie ist momentan in Rente.
Aber früher hat sie als Schneiderin gearbeitet.
Der Vater der Patienten leidet an Demenz,
erlebt im Altenheim.
Die Mutter der Patienten ist mit 60 Jahren
an einem Rungenkassionum verstorben.
Die Schwester der Patienten hat vor einem Jahr
an einer Herzinfarkt gelitten.
Die Analystischen Alten deuten am Herst und auf einen
Herzinfarkt hin.
Differenz in Diagnostik kommt auch eine Lungenembolie
und eine globale Herzinspezie in Betracht.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich das Monitoring eingeleitet.
Was machen Sie jetzt Diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Sie haben die Körperlichte untersucht.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung?
Beim Isplixion erinnern wir eine Tordex-Angst.
Bei dieser Patient gibt es keine Schwitzen.
Außerdem überprüfen wir Geschwollenerbeinen.
Beim Auskutation hören wir eine mögliche Herzstolpe,
Herzrasen oder eine mögliche Anderherzerkrankung ab.
Haben Sie die Labortechnik schon etwas angeleitet?
Ja, genau.
Wir müssen auch Tropen in OCK-MB überprüfen.
Wir müssen die Tropen in der Gerichtskrise überprüfen.
Wir müssen sie einmal pro 2 Stunden wiederholen.
Außerdem können wir unspecifische Blutuntersuchung überprüfen.
Wir müssen die Laborte, die Nierenwerte, die andere, die Gerinnungssperre,
die Elektrolippe auf.
Gegenüber die Erfansprobe brauchen wir auch eine Ekokardiografie.
Mit dieser Untersuchung können wir mögliche Herzerkrankungen beschnitten.
Zum Beispiel können wir Herzwände oder Herzklappen oder Herzraume
können wir auch gut erkennen.
Wenn ich das bestätige, dass die erhöhte Troponienwerte hat,
dass sie wirklich einen Infarkt hat,
was ist das therapeutische Mittel der Wahl?
Bei der Therapie legen wir 2 Zugang im Wänen.
Dann verabreichen wir Morphine und natürlich mit Maske,
Oxygen, Sauerstoff.
Auch verabreichen wir Nitrat, Aspirin, Antikorgen,
wie zum Beispiel Heparin.
Es gibt auch noch ein Verfahren, das Diagnostik und
Therapie verbindet.
Wenn es innerhalb 120 Minuten eine PTCA möglich ist,
führen wir eine PTCA durch.
Mit dieser Untersuchung können wir so etwas diagnostieren
als auch Therapie-Einleitung.
Gut.
Dann bin ich gespannt, was bei den Untersuchungen
Ihrer Patientin rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden über diese Patientin
und dann gucke ich heute Abend mal bei der Patientin rein
und gucke mal, wie es ihr geht.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Dr. Gündisch, was sagt der Karte?
Ich möchte eine Erinnerung sagen.
Das ist ein Verdachtdiagnost.
Der Verdachtdiagnost ist im Akutes Coronar-Sendron.
Akutes Coronar-Sendron,
non-ST-Mio-Mio-Karte-Impaktus,
ST-Hebunk-Mio-Karte-Impaktus,
instabilisieren,
das ist möglich.
Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Das läuft hier tatsächlich als Angenapektoris-Fall?
Ja, das ist ein Angenapektoris.
Warum?
Aber wir müssen, wie viele Minuten hat es gedauert?
Ja, wir müssen ja, wenn 20 Minuten und hoch dauert,
instabilisieren.
Und mehr und mehr, dann ist es ja.
Ja, aber solange hat es bestimmt, glaube ich, eher nicht gedauert,
dass ich glaube, dann hätte die auch sofort die 1 als 2 angerufen.
Also, da werde ja mit der Feuerwehr gekommen.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, Troponinwerte erhöht.
Wir müssen immer Akutes Coronar-Sendron denken und schreiben.
Ah ja, okay.
Gut, ja, jetzt vielleicht kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich würde sagen, für erste Anamnesi hier in dieser Runde, Top,
also wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Was ich zum Brüllen finde, ja, aber klar, Sie sind in Bayern,
dass Sie mich mit Grüß Gott begrüßt haben.
Das macht man natürlich in Süddeutschland.
Aber ich finde, das wäre schamant, muss ich sagen.
Und ja, ansonsten, es war wirklich, es war alles drin.
Sie sind sehr schön auf die Patientin eingegangen.
Sie haben natürlich auch super reagiert, dass Sie gesagt haben,
ist ein Notfall, müssen wir Monitoring machen.
Ja, und dann haben wir eben diese Prüfungssituation weiter gespielt.
Da haben Sie sehr gut reagiert.
Eine Winzigkeit, zwei Winzigkeiten sind mir aufgefallen.
Aber das sind, glaube ich, wirklich Hörfehler.
Das war Satan, nimmt sie komischerweise, nimmt sie das morgens
und nicht morgens und abends.
Sie nimmt es nur morgens, wobei ich das inzwischen gelernt habe,
dass man eigentlich die Sataner abends nehmen muss, ja.
Und die Mutter ist tatsächlich nicht an einem Lungenkarzinom gestorben,
sondern sie ist an einem Leberkarzinom gestorben.
Vielleicht habe ich das nicht deutlich gesagt, das könnte sein.
Und ansonsten, ja, also die Anamnese fand ich, fand ich sehr zugewandt
und sehr, sehr systematisch auf.
Und auch in Ihrem Bericht sind Sie eigentlich sehr zügig gewesen.
Das war alle entscheidenden Sachen gesagt.
Und also ich würde sagen, Sie können dieser Prüfung deutlich entspannter entgegen gucken.
Ja, das müsste nach menschlichem Ermessen gut klappen.
Ja.